hey what's up my name's Samuel lead and
I'm a property investor and this week
I'm going to be answering some of your
property questions that you've got that
have been niggling you bugging you and
let's see what we got from last week so
property investment with Dennis says hey
Sammy what I hope you're doing great I
am man I'm doing grand he says question
do you follow up agents when they say no
to you I believe that no today doesn't
mean no forever
if you do follow up what's your
consistency how many times a week or a
month and what do you say to them yeah
really good question um I haven't really
got like a formula for this I kind of
just go off my gut feeling if I speak to
someone or if I speak to an agent and I
think oh this person sounds promising
this person sounds good
I don't sort of write down I'm gonna die
arise to call them in three months I'm
just kind of more I guess the way I
operate is I'm always phoning people I'm
always pushing I'm always so I'm not
running out of leads so I think you'll
probably my guess is from a maybe
professional or corporate backgrounds
where you have like a list and you may
be which isn't a bad thing it's just not
the way I do it if they say to me no go
away or no we don't do that or ah how
dare you put in that cheeky offer and
and I just sense that they're very in
then I don't call them back I don't
think although we're in a bad mood that
day I'll call them up next week and see
if they're feeling better I just have to
write them off of course depending on
who said it it might not be the whole
agency as a whole it might be that
particular person if they say you here's
the important thing do they understand
what you're looking for if they do you
see if they if I say to them I'm looking
for us some discount so I'm looking for
some motivated sellers one prepared to
get some really cheap properties have
you got anything in stock and they say
yo-yo will soon do an email some
properties like they said yes
technically but they don't understand
I'd rather them say you know what I get
what you're looking for you looking for
some motivated sellers I understand that
right now we don't have anyone like that
but I fully understand where you're
coming from
I'd rather that and I'll be ringing them
for sure I'll be bringing them back or
giving me their details for them to call
me so it's more about people
understanding what you want as an
investor or as a property entrepreneur
it's the same as if I'm trying to rent a
rent and someone says we don't have any
landlords that will consider corporal
let's all that kind of agreement but I
get your man I understand what you're
trying to do and it makes sense for me
that's mega if it makes sense to the
agent I'll be their best friend and all
will be I will be following up for sure
so I hope that helps keep making those
calls butter games Dean James Dean says
should I always aim for a high return on
investment regardless of the area is
high ROI a sign of a good deal if not
what is I don't live in the UK and
Department prices in our capital city
are skyrocket high whereas the rent
income is very low below 5% return on
investment I don't know where you're
from what country from but what I would
say is if the aura is bad the deals bad
that is it end of story and I think you
already know that really you just want
me to say it if your ROI is 5% as
terrible if the house is all the
apartments are high and the rents low
that that's the opposite of what my
books called my books called buy low
rent high you're telling me in your area
it will be but it'll be buy high rent
low which is which is going to give you
a terrible ROI there's two ways that you
might profit when you buy a house you
make you make your money from the
capital appreciation as the house goes
up and you make your money from the
ongoing rent cabbage depreciation is
brilliant but it doesn't pay the bills
the ROI the money that you'll get in
each month is the most important thing
you want to put in as little as possible
and get out on a monthly basis as much
as possible so the ROI is all I've been
looking for I don't care what country
the house is in I don't care if it's in
England if it's in Spain all I care
about is there's going to be giving me a
good ROI and it's passive I've got a
systemized Power Team looking after it
if those two things that I'm good
capital appreciation do
not pay the bills and you know you can't
Bank on it you know you can predict it
to a point you can say this area's
bottom doubt it's gonna now go up but
you've got a look at the ROI so James
Dean stick to your instincts keep
looking for ROI hi baby
not low we got little pump little pump
says Samuel knowing what you know now if
you had 10 know a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand pounds to start
investing in property what would you do
with it I'm also very grateful for your
content you put out thanks man I
appreciate that little pump you've got a
hundred grand and that was it and I'm
starting out well over the game of what
I do I would probably buy a couple of a
couple of houses that needed to be
restoring and then I would restore them
and then I would pull the money out put
my money back out on the two houses and
then do it again stop building a
portfolio that way it's not the easiest
but because of my knowledge it's
probably the best way to pull your money
back out you know what I know now though
I could just raise the money and go
crazy I'm pretty confident that I'd be
able to raise a lot of money help but
make a lot of people wealthy become
wealthy myself starting out again I
asked Robert Kiyosaki actually the same
question and he said he said that he is
kind of an irrelevant question because
he wouldn't need the hundred grand in
the first place because there is
knowledge and his ability to be able to
raise money so I've got a really we can
relate to that so but that's probably
what a dope you know what it depends on
what you're out what your long-term goal
is if your goal is to built is your goal
to build wealth or is it to get out of a
job then let's pick there's so many
different reasons people get into
property but for me if I had 100 grand
and I was wanting to start all over
again I'll be wanting to build build a
portfolio and I think the fastest way to
build my own portfolio will be to buy we
refurbish we finance repeat and went
what are you thoughts on Liverpool Jamel
says for buying property cash renting
refinancing and carrying on same thing
man
littles good it was really good
Liverpool's I think saw what l2
one area is rising now but Liverpool's
one of the areas it's funny I think no
pausing to do really well and the reason
I say that is because everywhere follows
London and London London crashed in 2008
then roundabout 2011 shot massively up
2011 to 2016 those five years many parts
of London doubled in value and then it
dipped and now it's not sure what to do
and Birmingham followed
Birmingham's now probably beginning to
peak now
Birmingham's probably well London was in
2016
Manchester a few years behind Manchester
is exploding right now has been in first
couple few years it's got a long way to
go little thought hasn't Liverpool's
just but still just sat there but I well
it's beginning to happen in some parts
of Liverpool
so I predict it's gonna go up but again
trying to work out the Cubs appreciation
it doesn't pay the bills you can just
got a look at the ROI you got a look at
what you're putting in what you getting
out so yeah I think I think I think
never balls good I think that it's not
it's not so much about the area it's
more about the person and it's more
about I mean I could make money pretty
much anywhere because I would adapt what
I'm doing to fit with that market so you
can make money in Liverpool you can lose
money Liverpool you just got to have the
skills but I like it a little what would
you do yourself if you were young and
broke and wanted to start from nothing
well be your first steps something I
pretty much did that and filmed it so
you can go ahead and watch it financial
freedom challenge just Google Samuel
Leeds financial freedom challenge I
think the title is millionaire starts
again with nothing and what I did was
like I packaged some deals I sold those
deals made some money with that money
put it down as down payments for some
rent to rents and then I was financially
Fred it in seven days man that's what I
say the importance of knowledge people
think that you need money and then
knowledge is helpful and networks
helpful no no no knowledge and network
environment is everything the money I
lost everything I have financially
I can honestly say I wouldn't be that
bothered because I know what make it all
back yeah you win the lottery and you
know you take the average lottery winner
in five ten years they're broken again
it really is not about the money it's
about the knowledge the mindset the
environment the support network so I
can't stress that enough
Florine a Radu a Marian pop says so if I
stay let's say in Romania and I've come
to the UK to do a lease option agreement
what should I do
or can I even do that by the way I'm 18
I'm asking because the UK is still in
the EU can I still go and stay there
with just my passport okay I can't speak
for like whether you can come on what
these are and all that because I don't
really know can you do a lease option
agreement here absolutely you absolutely
can you can do you can do a lease option
with no money no credit bad credit from
Romania like anyone could do a lease
option because all you're doing is
you're not actually buying the house
you're agreeing to buy it down the line
so it's buy now pay later and to secure
one of those you can start making good
cash flow and then good capital
appreciation living in Romania for sure
I've got a lot of students that are
international doing that kind of thing
so I hope that was helpful guys if
you've got spin-off questions or if
you've got unrelated questions as long
as it's kind of property related comment
below and then next week on Sunday at 7
p.m. I'll be answering some of your
questions as well thank you so much for
the support I hope that was helpful and
I just really appreciate you watching
and engaging with the video so I'll see
you tomorrow as well I'm doing a video
every single day 7 p.m. be there or be
square
you